let's go next - oh you know what let's
go to Dante from Florida who often has
interesting takes we haven't heard from
him for a while Dante is a Bernie
supporter who at one point flirted with
supporting Tulsi but now he is strongly
Bernie right Dante I think this time I
got it right uh I was never really
flirting with supporting Tulsi Gabbard I
just always like what she was doing with
her Candace candidacy and the foreign
policy issues that she brought up so
always try to give her some attention
when it's when I get the chance all
right but you were never considering
supporting her you were always Bernie
then yeah who's always Bernie
gotcha okay what's going on Dante told
oh that was actually something I wanted
to ask you about because I wanted you to
clarify your position about not
endorsing a candidate in the primary
because it doesn't really make sense to
me so if you could explain that what do
you want me to explain your reasoning
for why you don't want to support and a
candidate or endorse a candidate or what
you think they might lead to because I
think from the explanation you said you
don't want to add to the the circular
firing squad on the left or something
like that by supporting one candidate
over the other yeah listen I mean I'm
nobody I'm just a guy who's analyzing
politics everybody who watches my show
I think understands my positions you
know I've seen that there has been an
attempt lately to smear me as saying
that Bernie and Warren are the same it's
like you know I've been clear they're
not the same Bernie comes from a farm or
left place than Elizabeth Warren a lot
of their policies today are very similar
but you know for example Elizabeth
Warren voted in favor of scaling up
funding for the military something that
I'm against Bernie voted against it like
they're not the same I've been I've been
abundantly clear at this point I just
like what what do we gain my by me
coming out and saying I am endorsing
this person over that person when the
truth is I'm going to vote
for whoever is the eventual Democratic
nominee I'm not going to hide who I vote
for in the primary I mean Liz I'm just
uncovering the issues and the candidates
I don't see what advantage there is to
me now coming out and saying I'm all
about this candidate over that candidate
I mean listen like it's no secret I've
made it clear Bernie is to the left of
Elizabeth Warren and I would vote for
either of them and I think it's
imperative that we remove Donald Trump
like what would an endorsement do it
what would you like would it make a
difference if I endorsed one person or
another like you're supporting Bernie
you know that that's fine you know what
it's not really the endorsement part
it's more that you have a show and I
think it's important to be crystal clear
about it and leave no room for ambiguity
in the audience that Bernie Sanders is
clearly better he's just a better
candidate it's not that he's good on
some issues and he's better than
Elizabeth Warren on some issues and
she's pretty good on others she's like
it's it's not even close Bernie Sanders
well but but I'm saying you understand
that that's that's your opinion right
but you you say you you host a program
in your Social Democrat and up if you're
a Social Democrat it's not really close
you say that Bernie Sanders is more
foreign leagues more or less yes so by
your estimation that meeting is better
because your Social Democrats reboot the
social democratic ideology of like
social democratic economic reform and
non interventionist foreign policy and
progressive tax system is the best way
to run the country and Bernie Sanders is
more aligned with you on those issues so
he's the best candidate so I guess
that's the point I'm trying to make is
it's not that I think you should endorse
him because of our boost that I think it
would give to Bernie Sanders I think
it's just important to be clear that if
you're someone who wants real like
structural change fundamental change in
US politics like
a political revolution it's not like you
can just o choose either one and it'll
it'll be basically the same or be close
to the same it's very business very big
different but Dante let me ask you a
question at the end this is a thought
experiment okay so don't don't go crazy
and I don't want people in the audience
to go crazy let's imagine we all agree
without placing a value judgment on
anything we agree Bernie is to the left
of war and it sounds like you and I are
on the same page about that right you
said it and I'm saying it now Dante are
you mean you get it hold on that's it
but we're just starting I'm just I'm
laying it out for you you and I both
agree Bernie is to the left I'll go
right
yeah okay
imagine that we became convinced that
even though bernie is further to the
left of Warren this is hypothetical that
Warren's policy is more likely to become
a reality for whatever reason right this
is hypothetical would it then still be
just as clear to you that that we are
better off by putting in someone who is
further to the left but less likely to
accomplish things this is just a
hypothetical this is just me saying just
because we identify who's further left
that that's not all there is to it would
you agree that there's some element
there that we would we would have to
consider about that in the hypothetical
but here in the real in the real world
in the 2020 primary and we can we can
look at their record and we could look
at what they plan on doing okay Bernie
Sanders even though his policies could
humbly see more radical he has a better
chance of passing me because he has a
actual plan of doing it Elizabeth Warren
she has not really explained how she
wants to get any of these things done
because she's not in favor of primary
and corporate Democrats like Bernie
Sanders is he's not she's not going to
bust up the establishment like Bernie
Sanders is he's not gonna she's not
going to do rallies and joe Manchin
state when he votes against Medicare for
all like Bernie Sanders said he would
write Oh Bernie Sanders is bringing
grassroots pressure so he but his
policies are
and here's a better chance of passing it
yeah okay but again Dante
that's right you're you seem to be
mistaking so I'm trying to have a
conversation with you about what you
first brought up which is just about you
know the the the idea of whether I
should or shouldn't be endorsing someone
but now you're just making it you're
saying well your opinion is a B and C
about Bernie but I'm trying to have a
different conversation with you you know
what I mean I think we're talking past
each other no uh it's not that I'm
christmasing your opinion you just
brought up the fact that it's it might
not be crystal clear that that Bernie
Sanders is the best because he might be
able to get hurt it's not about policy
sack but I'm saying
all right listen bull Dante I think the
takeaway I got a lot of people holding
so I'm gonna let you go but the takeaway
is you think that morally I should be
making an endorsement on the program no
it's not morally I think that you should
just be clear with the audience and make
sure that there's no room for
interpretation Elizabeth Warren she's
not gonna challenge the the political
establishment I believe not I've been
clear with that so my if you go back
Dante to my first see this is the
problem I have that I am being clear but
there's a lot of propaganda misstating
my position so for example if you go
back to the first clip I did about it's
called something like there are serious
differences between Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders the primary thing that I
state is that although they've come
close on policy in 2019 now 2020
Bernie's approach is of totally read
that the system is broken and you need
to change the system at its core whereas
Elizabeth Warren comes from the camp of
fixing the things about the system that
are broken in my first clip pointing out
the differences between the two of them
I did exactly what you're pointing out I
haven't done I'm not saying you haven't
done it but I'm saying they just said it
Dante that you should be clear in
because that's it's not just me other
people who watch this show come with the
same takeaway there all right well
listen
other people all right Dante point taken
let's make it about let's make it about
you I appreciate what you're saying
and don't worry you're going to know who
I vote vote for that I promise you okay
thank you
all right Dante thank you very much
let's take a quick break if you are
holding don't hang up because we will be
going right back to the phones after
this